now life is getting harder and it's
feeling more dangerous and the liberal
Utopias like San Francisco where we just
were or La Philly Chicago
regular sane people are getting tired of
paying through the nose for decline in
quality of life
and as we've seen in New York well
they're just deciding I'm going to pick
up and move
now seeing a lot of four lease signs I
have over the last few days they're
hanging in all the office building
windows
and one real estate expert is warning of
a permanent collapse of real estate
commercial real estate due to what's
being called an urban Doom Loop oh my
God it sounds awful
of course who would want to make the
Trek into the city when it seems that
criminals have the run of the place
especially with leftist prosecutors like
New York's Alvin Bragg in charge as a
Soros back prosecutor he doesn't
consider Prosecuting career criminals a
top priority
he considers a top priority to be
hunting down Heroes like subway Good
Samaritans Daniel penny that's one of
his most important missions
now Bragg wants to make an example out
of Mr penny
and it's something like this defend
yourself or defend others and you're
doing it at your own risk
the risk of prosecution
now naturally Bragg gets the high five
on all this from New York's
neo-socialist governor
no person should ride the subway even if
they're having a mental health episode
and be killed for that there's excessive
force which I believe was used here this
family deserves Justice
wow and now things are getting worse
brag is widening the net according to
the New York Post tonight investigators
appear to have identified one of the two
men seen on the video helping Penny now
the sources said authorities have been
scouring surveillance footage looking
for them and so I'm thinking to myself
do they simply want to question these
two men as potential Witnesses
well considering it's brag that's
doubtful more likely he wants to bag a
few accomplices to more vigilante scalps
on the wall
now this is a sick man hunt for two men
who did nothing wrong
two nights ago we interviewed a woman
who was brutally beaten in the subway
she told us things could have been
different if someone like Mr Penny was
around
I would never be the same again I'm not
that person that I was seven months ago
and if I had somebody like Penny around
maybe things would have been different I
probably wouldn't have suffered so much
pain and suffering and these things that
I go through
well she lost one of her eyes because of
that attack
and so much more her life was completely
shattered now she planned to join us
tonight
until she called and told us she had
received too many death threats
please pray for her and all the victims
of crime and every city in this country
Elizabeth Gomes isn't the only one
though who thinks this way about Daniel
penny
and my girlfriend used the train very
often and she always feel uncomfortable
it's not supposed to be like that
there's a lot of crazy things that are
happening in this city right now and
it's like
just scary to be out someone does attack
you you need to do something and
whatever it takes you know do it if he
didn't do anything what now what happens
could I heard a child or a woman
pregnant woman
and a witness on the train a woman of
color who's about 64 years of age spoke
exclusively to Fox News digital
and described how she felt when Penny
stepped up as a real man would
she said he's a hero it was self-defense
and I believe in my heart that he saved
a lot of people that day
that day that could have gotten hurt the
people on that train we were scared we
were scared for our lives
and that's just how the left wants you
isn't it scared
too scared to act too scared to speak
out too scared to stand up for your
right to self-defense
now the only way to change this Dynamic
to turn the tide against this criminal
element and the prosecutors who Shield
them is to throw the bombs out
if the cities want change they'll have
to change the voting habits and
courageous men and women will need to
step forward and lead the way hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else